it's interesting to me that there's a
bunch of people that could say
you know because you you get on The
Walking Dead you're on it from the
beginning and it's such this iconic
character you get to play and
you really nail it and then famously
you're you're killed not just once but
twice oh yeah you know because you can't
you can't take John Bernthal out with
just one you've got it
trust me I've tried he's just this man
will not die and so but you you you get
off the series and so there are a lot of
people that might think and then that's
just obviously the series this is
starting to gain momentum and so there
might be some people that would think
well [ __ ] that was I wish I could have
stayed on for 10 years 11 years but
actually I think for someone like you
that frees you up it's in its own way
it's a gift because then you get to go
on and do all these other things and
um and show who you are and show
different sides of yourself so to me I
often think there are many times in my
life where I've thought damn it it's
over it's over I screwed up it's over or
I wanted something to go my way it
didn't go my way and I'm done and I
guess that that's it and then when I
later on Google Earth and look at the
whole picture I realized that was the
greatest thing that could have happened
to me at that moment of course yeah it's
always
um I really try to exercise not not not
calling it not not saying it's one way
or the other you know um sure at the
time I was like well this is right this
is just in line with everything else
that's ever happened in my life you know
it's like here we are I finally got on
the show it's finally taken off and boom
they got me the hell out of there you
know like pack up your [ __ ] and go and
and I remember going back to The Walking
Dead to go pick up my truck and I
remember like walking out and seeing
them sort of shoot this first episode
that I wasn't going to be in and I
wanted to go say goodbye to everyone and
instead of saying goodbye I just sat on
this rock in the woods and just watched
this beautiful sort of Symphony of the
barn was on fire and there were all
these zombies and I saw Norman doing his
thing and Scott Wilson rest in peace
just standing out on the you know
bellowing and and uh just this beautiful
you know crew and these people there in
my family and I saw them all working and
and
I just palpably understood that's that
that's you know I'm not part of that
anymore that's they're they're doing
their thing and I sat there and I weeped
and you know I felt sorry for myself and
I knew it was over and um look you know
the only thing I can I I can look at uh
with Walking Dead is just unbelievable
just full gratitude and it's just full
gratitude like what a what a privilege
what an honor what a what a thing to to
play a character with a real beginning
middle and end but more than anything
you know Stephen and Norman and Scott
and Melissa and irony and Sarah and and
Andy I mean these are like lifelong
friends who who really taught me how to
be an artist and a father and a husband
all at the same time and to to trim so
much fat off your life and Whittle it
down and and those are the guys
those are are my closest friends you
know in in this business and you I mean
you know those guys I mean they're
they're beautiful human beings yeah
we've interviewed just I think I've
interviewed everyone you've mentioned
they're great people great people I
would have handled that differently I
would have been sitting on the truck and
watching them shoot a scene without me
now that I'm gone and I would have just
started screaming I don't [ __ ] need
you ruining every time
Conan can you please you had two good
years yeah and roll let's go action can
we get him out [ __ ] you
and then I do like donuts in my truck be
knocking over zombies they'd be like
come on man all right Larry's and Danzig
yeah
to to feel a second of that pain or to
to wonder and and and uh but yeah
looking back at it without a doubt you
know doing that show was the best thing
that ever happened to me in in my career
and then I think getting killed off was
the best thing that ever happened to me
in my career and I'm I'm just I'm I'm
flabbergasted and grateful for for all
of it